good morning sir how are you doing good
how you doing
i'm doing good so um we are talking the
movie has literally come out last night
uh it's already doing pretty well what
kind of mood are you in
i'm good i'm excited it's finally out
you know waited five years for this
weekend and uh
i'm excited for people to see it on the
big screen
speaking of the big screen uh i want to
talk to you specifically about imac
stuff um i am curious you've you've
probably traveled the world uh do you
have a favorite imax theater
that's good question uh
you know i'd say the one that i like
going to is the one i go to most which
is the mastering theater
uh here in ply del rey which you know
well
but that's where you go to check your
film and and make the adjustments uh for
imax and it's um
it's small in terms of seating for an
imax but it's uh it's in their
headquarters and it's always an exciting
time to go there because it means you're
getting uh you're getting close you've
obviously seen a lot of movies in imax
do you have a favorite movie experience
of like going to see a movie in imax and
just um just a great experience with you
know do you have a favorite movie moment
the one that comes to mind is
one of my first imax experiences which
was probably at a science center in the
80s
and it was i can't remember which film
it was but i remember the shot was like
a race car going across the desert
and then it cut to a pov on the front
and all of a sudden the camera went off
a cliff
and you were flying
and
the camera like tilted down and i
remember
the feeling of like losing your stomach
while sitting in
a movie theater and uh
that was probably one of my first imax
experiences and one that certainly made
a huge impression it's funny you say uh
a racing car because i think that's what
you're doing next so maybe that's been
with you since you were a kid yes and
finally get to fulfill yet another
childhood dream listen a lot of people
are gonna have choices on where to see
top gun maverick there's a lot of
different theater you know theaters that
are showing it uh what did you do to
make top gun maverick such like an imax
experience
well we have almost an hour of the film
is in
full imax format
so
which is mostly the flying scenes
you'll get to experience uh in a imax
filling
aspect ratio
so that's going to be something you can
only get in an imax theater
uh and for people that don't realize i
believe that it's like an extra 26
of the screen fills in could you sort of
talk about that yeah it's uh
typically most of the film you know is
at um
a two point three nine to one aspect
ratio the widescreen aspect ratio which
is
you know i think is great for the drama
on the ground um it's it's uh you know
keeps those dramatic scenes intimate but
when we go into the air
yes you get 26 percent more
the black bars on the top and bottom of
the frame disappear
and you get a kind of
vision filling
image that will really capture
the experience of being one of these
airplanes i believe you use the sony
venice imax cameras um can you talk
about why why you use those cameras
well the sony venice is a large format
camera so it has a larger sensor than um
a 35 millimeter film camera um
so uh it allows them to pack more pixels
into it so it's a 6k
sensor uh and it just
i found the sony cameras i've shot every
film
um with claudio uh we've always used the
sony camera going back to tron legacy uh
and i just find that the way it
reproduces color um
is uh very natural and it's just worked
for for our style
so this is the latest iteration and it
comes in a model called the rialto
that'll that allows it to to go to a
very small form factor so that we could
fit six of them
in the cockpit of the
f-18 with the actors so what you're
seeing on screen was captured for real
and
the result is you're gonna not only get
the
the sense of speed and light and sky and
movement that you get from being in an
airplane but you're gonna actually see
the forces
on their bodies as they pull g's
um flying in these uh amazing machines
you mentioned you have six cameras uh
and an f-18 cockpit is not very large
can you sort of talk about could talk
about the camera and how you can
actually put it in the cockpit
well it it the camera allows you to
separate the recorder from the lens so
uh by separating it the the lens is is
small enough that we figured out a way
to mount six of them in the cockpit and
hide the recorders
down in the cockpit where typically they
have other equipment so we had the navy
strip out all the equipment they didn't
need
uh to fly the plane and we stuffed
camera gear
um
in those places uh and if you look
really closely while you watch the movie
you'll see little camera wires running
along the edge of the cockpit which we
just left in there because we just
thought it was cool uh to see you know
the gear that we used to shoot the film
and what's funny is most people who are
going to watch it are just going to
think that's gear that's part of the
plane yeah yep exactly so that's why it
didn't bother me but it's it's proof
that we did shoot it for real uh did you
ever think you mentioned that uh the
dramatic scenes you wanted to be in the
in the normal screen did you ever think
about shooting the entire movie in imax
well we do capture the whole film full
frame so we have that ability
to open the whole film if we wanted to
but
um that extra headspace for those
dramatic scenes to me
uh didn't help you know it was good to
kind of keep it more intimate and then
open up the film for the um aerial
sequences so uh so that's the choice we
made so you're saying that when you're
shooting the movie in imax like this um
it doesn't change what you're doing on
set at all it's just a question of what
you're doing in the editing room yeah
it's when when do you want to open up
and use the full frame and when do you
want to be at the more classic
uh 239 aspect ratio the the flying
sequences in your movie are so
incredible and i've never seen anything
like it do you think that this film
could have been made like a year before
you shot it or was it only because like
the technology of the cameras were like
meeting the you know what i mean yeah
well
before the the rialto um i don't think
we would have been able to fit six
cameras it probably would have been
one or two
um
so
the cover the amount of coverage would
have been less we wouldn't have had much
variety and as much choice in the edit
to show different
angles um so
it would have been harder
and it just i don't think would have
been as good as what we were able to do
with that camera actually work directing
the actors when they're in the cockpits
with all these cameras around them was
it one of these things where you're
directing them before they go up giving
them instructions and then looking at
the footage when they get back down or
how did that work yeah yeah it's more
like a play where you're doing a lot of
rehearsal
and then when the performer goes up
they're performing on their own so
we would do every flight day we would
have a two-hour brief with all the
pilots all the actors
me tom claudio eddie our editor
and we would go through every single
shot of the day
in like this long
tedious briefing process
then
uh i would go down into the hangar with
the actor and the aviator who were gonna
fly
and we had a mock-up of the f-18 cockpit
built out of wood
that was an exact mock-up with all the
gauges and had the switch for the
cameras and had little mock-ups of where
the cameras were and we would sit there
and rehearse for about an hour every
thing they needed to do on their flight
uh and once we had that committed to
like muscle memory then we would send
them up in the jet they would shoot for
an hour they'd come back we'd load the
footage in we'd all watch it together
uh and we'd cheer them when they did
something right and we'd give them notes
when they did something wrong and then
we'd send them up in the afternoon and
do it again so it was a very tedious
process that you know over a 14 hour
work day you might just get a minute or
two of usable footage but
um what you did get was something you
couldn't get any other way so i'm
curious what is it like mastering a
movie in imax can you sort of compare
what's what is it like mastering spider
head to say top gun maverick
yeah well top gun is something that you
will go to that feeder i was talking
about in playa del rey and you'll put
the picture up on the 90 foot screen
and you'll make adjustments to the
potentially the color the brightness the
grain structure things that you need to
pay attention to when you're looking at
something
that large
spider head you know i mastered that on
a more traditionally sized movie screen
because that's the largest it will be
seen um
so it is slightly different but
uh in terms of my approach to making it
i don't
frame for a streaming
uh title versus an imax title i tried to
you know
i think my style is just kind of to try
to uh tell the story with the best shots
i can come up with what is it like after
spending years making a movie
sitting in the imax theater mastering
the film and realizing like do you ever
second guess oh my god this do i want
this a little darker do i want this a
little brighter like how much are you in
your head when you're mastering a movie
uh very much um you you end up
go doing a pass through the film and
then going away for a couple days and
coming back and doing it again because
uh you definitely always have those
voices in your head
as you think about things um
and uh always tweaking up to the last
minute that's just the nature of
filmmaking i mean it's literally like
what people don't realize it's it's the
director acting as a painter you're
literally painting the movie
yeah you can uh you can affect it a lot
in the grade i mean hopefully at that
point you've got a pretty good sense
of what it is you're going for even if
it's a rough version in the avid
um but i like to do it with claudio you
know next to me um since you know he's
the cinematographer and we we shot it
together um
and yeah it's fun it's really for me
it's a fun part of the process if you
could ask imax to design a new camera or
cameras to help you as a filmmaker um
when you're filming a movie what would
you what would that request be smaller
is always better
um you know especially for a movie like
this from the movie i'm prepping now you
know which is dealing with uh
cars you know very fast cars on a race
track um trying to get cameras in places
um interesting places give the audience
perspectives um they've never had before
smaller lighter
is always a good thing is the 6k chip
that's in the venice camera like you
don't really do you need a chip that's
better quality or is it literally just
about shrinking the camera with the
current chip that you're using
i think the quality is is there i mean
the the projection format now is 4k so
we're already have more resolution
uh than we need which is good um in case
you want to you know
blow into something a little bit you
want to have that extra resolution but
yeah it's it's just about getting the
you know if you can get it down to just
a sensor and a lens
um that would be ideal because you could
put it anywhere as you know i i love the
imax format and and think it's the way
to watch movies um do you see yourself
in the future with like the movie you're
working on now and things down the road
do you think imax will always be a
component that you would like to you
know collaborate with absolutely you
know the great thing about an imax
theater is when you walk into it you
know the picture is going to be bright
enough
the sound is not going to be turned down
at all it's going to be loud
the quality of the experience is
maintained across all their theaters so
you're not going to get a bad
experience yeah you're going to get a
reference quality experience and that's
what i think every director wants is the
audience to see
what he or she set up
during the finishing process and
and that they're going to see the same
thing you did on that note i'm just
going to say congrats on making
such an incredible movie and i really do
hope everyone chooses to see it in imax
because it's a spectacular experience
thanks man i appreciate it
you